hey guys it's Jo koy you can check my
specials out on Netflix there's
screaming right now I'm here to answer
some questions if you could be a part of
one fictional TV or movie crew who would
it be
Oh now when you say crew it has a
different definition now do you mean
crew is it like a sports team crew or
could it be crew like a b-boy crew
because they call themselves crew dead
dead dead dead dead dead dead yeah
that's called old man style like I used
to be a b-boy I don't know if you guys
know that OGP boyd 1984 man i did the
moonwalk across my gym floor and i was
the most famous kid in tacoma cuz i was
the only one i could do the moonwalk but
now my knees hurt when i do it but look
so crew oh I'm gonna go with a b-boy
crew and if I had a chance to be with
any crew it would be stop elements there
you go look it up google it
oh my god they're not even in TV or
movie by the way
starting today if you could get 10,000 a
day for every day you don't masturbate
how many days could you go without
jerking off twelve hours so that would
be five thousand dollars five thousand
bucks I'd probably make and I wanted it
I wanted in cash but don't give me a
check
go [ __ ] yourself would you rather be the
president the Pope or the ruler of North
Korea oh my god I mean that's that's a
no-brainer kim jungeun hands down when
you say let's party that means everyone
get the [ __ ] out of your house the
dictator wants to party
and you better act like you're enjoying
it you're not gonna be here tomorrow
I feed you to the dogs would you rather
watch your dad have sex with a
hundred-year-old man or watch your mom
kill some oh my god
this is really really tart oh yeah
I thought my mom killed someone man I'd
rather see my mom kill so alive this is
so bad maybe there would be a funny
moment like her just saying the words
wrong cuz she's cursing in English
she can't pronounce it right you [ __ ]
should die for this die [ __ ] dies
she's killing the guy he's like what is
[ __ ] like I want to go to heaven but
I don't want to go out there go not
knowing what the [ __ ] he said to me when
he killed me so my mom kill someone
would you rather your internet search
history go public or your sex tape Oh
viral
Oh God
that's basically hand and glove this
question it really is both are
detrimental oh oh man I've seen some
crazy stuff on the Internet my sex tape
game would never go viral yeah I think
for something to go viral it has to be
at least 30 seconds long right you can't
have you can't have a ten-second viral
tape that doesn't even exist but they
wouldn't they wouldn't go viral because
they wouldn't be able to add sell ad
space this video brought to you by oh
[ __ ] it's done you know what I'm gonna
go with my search history I've been kind
of good lately so if you're asking for
today's search history I've been pretty
good both plus uh I clear a lot of that
[ __ ] you're in a car chase with the
police what song is playing in your car
oh my god can I just tell a true story
right now of course as I've said this
before but I hit a cop in pursuit I hit
a cop with all his lights on and he was
going through a light and I smashed that
[ __ ]
two bits man I was driving a book a
Volkswagen Rabbit I don't even know if
they make that anymore with a moonroof
of the handle you had to open it like
this and I was [ __ ] going at least
fifty and I T polled this guy in the
intersection bro took the [ __ ] out and I
was listening the troop spread my wings
if you don't know that song it's an old
RB classic and it went spread my wings
and fly away to a place that I don't
know Duke car totaled right [ __ ] the
engine in my windshield everything
broken except the song No spread my
Louise and thigh away no horn going off
and follow away as I turn it down oh
yeah
it was probably a murder oh yeah yeah
yeah some murderers just going Thank You
mr. coy if your dick had a theme song
meaning every time you get hard this
song plays what's up would you pick oh
my god allow me to reintroduce myself
my name is Oh Oh then just [ __ ] fire
right shoot out of my balls and at the
intro with a twith it's a speech don't
don't don't don't don't don't slow
motion like like real like tardiness you
you know like just quittin don't don't
don't don't don't don't allow me to
reintroduce myself my name is Tom H to
the O V believe me the explosion helps
me out a lot if you could pick one
celebrity to have your back in a bar
fight who would it be
bro Sean Connery get the [ __ ] out of
here easy ask questions don't ask Seneca
and if it's not Sean Connery then it's
got to be
I don't know Bruce Lee I want to win the
fight
Oh Sean Connery are you kidding me
because one you would love to see him
fight and not only that you look at him
go
god he's he's [ __ ] gorgeous what a
gorgeous man are you guys taking this in
this man is getting his ass kicked by
the most gorgeous man in the world
please Sean continue you've got her
trocar one more punch fire pow oh look
at Jimmy Stewart's no profit oh boy yes
Lee would you have sex with your cousin
to win Powerball what no I could no
that's awful if it was a billion yeah
I'll have sex with them huh wait hold on
give me the next question if you were to
be murdered who is the most like oh my
god this is good
if you were to be murdered who is the
most likely suspect oh god this is a
good one this is a good one oh my god
damn it there's so many there's a lot
there's a lot um I would have to say the
cop I t-bone did the intersection yeah
and he'd know how to get away with it
for sure you come into my house like
Mark Wahlberg into departed
he's got surgical yeah he's got the foot
he's odd never meet [ __ ] spread
your wings [ __ ] far away you're gonna
have one thing free for the rest of your
life what do you choose oh my god I
would have to say the Seattle Coliseum I
would own it I would buy the arena I
would love to own an arena you know dope
that is to see jay-z walk in and own the
Brooklyn Nets you know me I would love
to walk in and everyone go hey that dude
owns this [ __ ] thing that would be me
one of these days I love you